our scripture the day proverbs 29:25 the
fear of man lays a snare but whoever
trusts in the Lord is safe
Florence Nightingale said how the very
little can be done under the spirit of
fear
one of our core values around here
sometimes we're afraid sometimes things
come at this business come at this
organization even come at me which
causes your heart rate to go up you know
a little bit of fear a little bit of
hangar kind of closely related right and
you just look at that and you go wow not
gonna make a decision based on that
because fear is really not a fruit of
the Spirit so I can't make decisions
based on fear now you won't be wise and
you know not you know don't touch a hot
stove you should be afraid of hot stoves
they'll burn your hand right but I'm not
gonna make decisions that are fear-based
if you make fear-based decisions let me
just tell you 100 percent of the time
it's the wrong decision and that's true
with your money too you ever hear people
call the show and they say I was forced
to buy a car I was forced to take this
job that's somebody's fear-based anytime
you feel like you were forced you
weren't
there's always another option might not
be a better option but the proper way to
say it then would be I looked at all the
other options there really weren't any
great ones so it took this option and
it's not a great option I was forced to
buy a car at seventy two percent
Interest though yeah you weren't either
no you weren't there were other ways
other things you could do you just
didn't want to do them and you're
desperate and right after I get
desperate you know what I get stupid and
you too